this morning on the dish the
self-proclaimed queen of easy peasy
sweets baker and cookbook author jessie
sheehan is all about creating fast yet
delicious desserts her newest collection
snackable bakes features an array of her
typically approachable recipes nancy
chen got a lesson and a taste on a visit
to her hometown
something's baking in the rolling
farmlands of northern connecticut now we
come to that moment where we add our dry
ingredients can i pour it oh i would
love it it's coming in fast you can put
it in all at once all right well there
you go
that's perfect
recipe creator and food writer jessie
sheehan is all about making sweets
simple i'm adding the leavening right
into my wet ingredients and then i'm
vigorously whisking that in the reason
that recipes are written to have you
combine your dry ingredients first is
they're worried about that leavening
her unabashed embrace of shortcuts
drives a brooklyn baker's latest venture
created at her new england farm this is
where you develop the recipes for your
cookbook a hundred percent i feel like
this is like the birthplace of snackable
bakes a tantalizing term she had coined
to describe her confectionary creations
now featured in a newly published
cookbook
what exactly is a snackable bake the
entire recipe is going to take you 20
minutes or less to assemble but in
general it is a fast and easy way to get
a sweet into your body as quickly as
possible i'm going to add about half of
this and then we're going to put some
pears in
that includes this pear sour cream
snacking cake she promises could be
assembled in just 10 minutes
the cake base is a sour cream cake with
like a teeny bit of cinnamon just to
kind of pop that fall pear vibe and then
you're literally sprinkling pears a
little bit on the inside a little bit on
the top and voila
it's very rich without feeling heavy
her recipes often melt contrasting
flavors
including black and white cupcakes with
a tangy pocket of cream cheese and
melted chocolate
when they first come out of the oven and
like the inside is really kind of gooey
heaven
there's also a rainbow sprinkle snacking
cake i like that you think of these
baked goods as snacks and you just pop
them in your mouth it's like kind of
normalizing sweets it's like you know 8
30 at night you're binge watching
something deliciously fun on tv and you
crave something and go in the kitchen
and make it and be eating it within like
less than an hour she does it
by simplifying ingredients and
condensing bakeware so there's less
cleanup
unexpected substitutes like mayonnaise
and cake also streamline her recipes do
you ever feel like you're cheating a
little bit with all this and is that
okay oh my gosh 100 cheating 100 percent
okay from an early age she loved eating
baked goods but never learned any
recipes herself
the massachusetts native was a theater
actress before practicing litigation for
three years in a new york city law firm
and i really believe that being in law
school taught me to be a really good
writer but oh my gosh nancy i hate
fighting so i was like the worst lawyer
because every single case i got i'm like
oh gosh can we please settle after the
birth of her two sons shane became a
stay-at-home mom
but at the age of 39 she wanted
something more how much did you know
about baking at that point
absolutely nothing like literally
nothing where else to go but the bakery
just down the street from her when i
think back on it now i can't believe i
did this i just went in and said hey hi
i'm a mom and i would love to learn to
bake what did they say well first they
were like okay can you like leave a note
for the head baker and i wrote my note
and i wrote like a million exclamation
points i was so enthusiastic and then
nobody called me so i go back and i
basically kind of said like apologies
for the exclamation points i'm
enthusiastic i would just like you guys
to teach me what it is you guys know at
first sheehan was kept far from the oven
but quickly learned the ropes and even
began contributing to the bakery's
cookbook all of that stuff came really
fast like literally from like i don't
know how to make a loaf cake too let me
write this recipe the lawyer in me meant
that i was like very
detail oriented
her methodical approach line itself to
not only writing recipes but also
developing creative approaches of her
own soon however there was another
transition
and challenge
at 41 i was diagnosed with breast cancer
i mean believe it or not i kind of
worked through the my treatment i would
love to be there and just see all of
those little jars filled with all those
delicious sparkly yummy treats to make
baked goods look beautiful and being
able to be distracted by whatever it was
i was doing all of it was like this
incredible gift after seven months of
treatment she unsuccessfully beat cancer
in two thousand nine
she then went on to publish cookbooks of
her own before exploring a new medium in
her fifties strawberry shortcake in a
mug peeps tick tock one tablespoon heavy
cream
melted butter spread spread spread the
total audience for her first two posts
3.7
million views here we have sweetened
condensed milk favorite
depressed we press and then we eat i
have no idea what came out of me but
this kind of crazy fast-talking slightly
aggro version of me popped out i'm back
we mix we mix one and a half cups of
chocolate chips that was pretty exciting
and also
i was flummoxed i'm like what does this
even mean how is this possible i'm
acting like an absolute lunatic and this
is what the kids want i would get
hilarious comments like grandma
grandma what are you making sheen's
viral success proved others also wanted
fast and approachable recipes and the
idea for snackable bakes was born and i
have to say now this has become like my
favorite
i don't even know what i would call this
a candy tart i mean you can smell it
like already but look how pretty that is
i just love that it really is just like
eating a reese's peanut butter cup
but as fulfilling as her desserts are
it's hard to beat the satisfaction of
the sweetest topping of them all
i feel like this is the moment in my
life where like i almost feel happiest
because this is truly truly truly what i
love to do it's like my most favorite
thing and i'm going to give you this job
if you can find something that you love
to do and you get to do that thing
that's like oh my god bananas it's so
great yeah it's icing yes a hundred
percent 100 that's icing for cbs
saturday morning nancy chen
sharon connecticut
and it looks so good we made them
actually cut out it was initially not
cut but i said we want to try something
this is hair like how good how good is
this beautiful
i love how her whole personality comes
out in the tick tock stuff like that and
i love how she says i'm acting like a
lunatic this is what the kids want
basically yeah that's it we'll be right
back
[Music]
[Applause]
no
what else these are the snickerdoodles
mars are these okay i love snow i love
snickerdoodles i wish not to love it who
doesn't love a snickerdoodle sugar and
cinnamon i love how nancy said bread
it's almost exactly like eating a
reese's peanut butter cup and i was like
but only better
better
she has found
the the secret to moist baking which
you know even some
professionals i've found that
haven't done such a great job nothing
like a good moist moist cake it's gotta
be moist and it was i love when she was
talking about she was a lawyer she
learned writing through being a lawyer
but she's like i hated arguing she's
like can we just settle
didn't want to go back not good
lawyering yeah
you might need a lawyer
for for posting your wordle today social
media oh no yes i did i did really bad
quite quite the uproar i i don't want to
know about
don't want to know about it but i was so
excited that i got the word
on the second
so she posted i i clicked on my social
media and i saw it i'm like well i guess
i'm not doing wordle today oh my god
that's all right
i'm sorry people i'm very very sorry
michelle's apology i know it's all right
we'll all live we'll all live well
we'll send um
snickerdoodles to everyone who uh
who was scared by it listen it's part of
people's mornings and they get sorry i
understand
it's a big deal